[Music]
give it away it'll be Rhonda Tom pass
Horford tried to squeeze it through
Rajan on the trail it's true holiday for
Anthony Davis now three minutes into the
contest lead by two steer in this
building also at home ad Suites throw
mean until almost a cabo ad with a nice
seal on Horford at megget Marcus Morris
and he goes to the line for a
three-point opportunity mozzarella
it'll be Darius Miller a challenge look
and ad snatches of four don't lie back
at it why not
you saw Marcus smart there he didn't eat
he knew what his plan was going to be
[Applause]
good luck they had the conversation
earlier where Rhonda was like go good
the pelicans are doing exactly what they
need to do already 14 points in the
paint eight free throws and they're
getting the ball to that guy he's
putting on a show he's six of eight
right now 12 five run Anthony Davis back
on the floor
Jamie's cold right on the bench like
that can't believe it I can't believe
they froze him out on the bed so that's
why they're given a Davie by the in
bounce money and 38.5 bells have their
biggest lead of the game once again to
the ball Tatum
take it away through Holliday picked
that clean just jumped his route
completely a be good entry let's true
holiday found him and the bells are up
now by 11 once again off the dribble
at 18 times of beautifully 11 in the
third for Kyrie Irving he thought more
on the run out sets up a DS wide open
69 67 Anthony Davis up to 31 and 10
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
save us from the devil's got it Dawkins
back up by 1/7 675 on the run maybe
stays with the plan and won't quit on
the play
Anthony Davis up to 35 Quinn taken to
Holliday got it down in a hurry
Anthony Davis inside they are coming get
me $37 ad what's it going to be
Anthony Davis quick catch and shoot at a
lid for the penalties for t-34 Anthony
Davis plus 3 / 3 and AD hammers it home
on the follow